OUR PLEA TO YOU TONIGHT, FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DVR THIS SHOW.
THERE MUST BE ENGINEERS AMONG
YOU CAN FIGURE IT OUT, WE WILL
SEE YOU TOMORROW.
THE GREAT SEAN HANNITY STANDING
BY IN NEW YORK CITY TO TAKE OVER
IN A 9:00 P.M. HOUR.
>> Sean: GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS,
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE START WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT,
IF YOU ARE LIKE MOST AMERICANS,
YOU DIDN'T WATCH TODAY'S
IMPEACHMENT CHARADE, HERE'S A
BIG TAKE AWAY.
ANOTHER HUGE DUD AND FRANKLY
UNEMBARRASSING SPECTACLE FOR THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE DOING, THIS
IS HUMILIATING TO ALL OF US, A
DISPLAY THAT NEEDS TO COME TO AN
END.
COMMON SENSE, REASON,
INTELLECTUAL HONESTY NEVER
PLAYED A PART IN ANY OF THIS.
NOTHING BUT ONE OPINION AFTER
ANOTHER OPINION, FOLLOWED BY A
CONJECTURE, AND HOW MY FEELINGS
ARE ABOUT WHATEVER.
NO EVIDENCE, NO WRONGDOING
WHATSOEVER, NONE.
ALL OF IT, EVERY BIT OF IT
HEARSAY AND THIS PERSONS
INTERPRETS AND TAPE INITIATION
INTERPRETA AND TAPE INITIATION
INTERPRETATIND TAPE INITIATION
INTERPRETATION TAPE INITIATION
INTERPRETATION AAPE INITIATION
INTERPRETATION ANDE INITIATION
INTERPRETATION AND TINITIATION
INTERPRETATION AND THAITIATION
INTERPRETATION AND THAT IATION
INTERPRETATION AND THAT PETION
INTERPRETATION AND THAT PERSON'S
INTERPRETATION AND A TRANSCRIPT
WHICH WE ALL READ.
THIS IS BLOWING UP THE DEMOCRATS
FACE AND AMERICANS ARE TUNING
OUT IN A BIG WAY.
VIEWERSHIP FROM THIS PUBLIC SHAM
DROPPED BY OVER A MILLION FROM
DAY ONE TODAY 2, AND I BET IT
DROPPED BY ANOTHER MILLION
TODAY, THE NUMBER AMERICANS
WATCHING ALREADY PALES IN
COMPARISON TO PREVIOUS
PROCEEDINGS.
CBS NEWS ACTUALLY DECIDED TO
PULL THE PLUG ON THEIR
WALL-TO-WALL COVERAGE EARLIER
TODAY IN EXCHANGE FOR REGULAR
PROGRAMMING, I WOULD EXPECT
OTHER NETWORKS WOULD PROBABLY
FOLLOW SUIT.
ACCORDING TO A MORNING CONSULT
POLL, THE FIRST HEARINGS UTTERLY
FAILED TO INCREASE ANY SUPPORT
FOR THIS CORRUPT, THIS
COMPROMISE, COMPROMISED SCHIFF
SHOW.
ANOTHER POLL IS SHOWING OVER
TWO-THIRDS OF AMERICANS HAVE
ALREADY MADE UP THEIR MINDS ON
THE SUBJECT, THEY KNOW IT ALL
COMES DOWN TO THE TRANSCRIPT,
THERE IS NO MYSTERY HERE AT ALL
DESPITE WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
TRYING TO CREATE, AN ENVIRONMENT
CIRCUS OF OUTCOME OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SMART.
THEY CAN EASILY READ THE NOW
PUBLIC TRANSCRIPT AT THE CENTER
OF THE SCHIFF SHOW AND NOT ONE
WITNESS WAS NECESSARY, NOT A
SINGLE ONE.
ON THAT TRANSCRIPT WHICH YOU CAN
READ, WHICH TODAY'S WITNESSES
CONFIRMED WAS ACCURATE AND
COMPLETE, NOT A SINGLE TIME --
HOW INTERESTING -- DID THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
EVER MENTION AID TO THE
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE.
AID WAS DELIVERED IN FULL, IT
WAS DELIVERED WITHOUT ANY
CONDITIONS AND IT WAS DELIVERED
WITHOUT UKRAINE HAVING TO DO
NOTHING AND DID NOTHING TO GET
THE AID.
THERE IS NO QUIT, NO PRO, NO QU
QUO -- HOW MANY MORE TIMES OF
THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT HAVE TO
SAY I DIDN'T HAVE ANY PROBLEMS
WITH ANY OF THIS?
DEMOCRATS NOW MAYBE WE WON'T
CALL IT A QUID PRO QUO, WE WILL
CHANGE THE NAME TO BRIBERY --
THAT WAS ONLY MENTIONED ONCE,
THAT WAS IN RELATION TO THE REAL
QUID PRO QUO, JOE BIDEN,
REMEMBER?
YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE MONEY,
YOU DON'T FIRE THE PROSECUTOR,
YOU DOLLARS,
YOU GOT SIX HOURS.
AFTER HE FIRED THE PROSECUTOR
WHO HE WAS TOLD WAS
INVESTIGATING HIS ZERO
EXPERIENCE SON, THEN I'LL GIVE
YOU THE BILLION -- WHY IS HIS
SON BEING PAID BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, NO EXPERIENCE IN
UKRAINE, NO EXPERIENCE IN OIL,
GAS, OR ENERGY?
BECAUSE HIS SON OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT, WATCH THIS.
>> MULTIPLE DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE GAVE TV AND
RADIO INTERVIEWS OVER THIS PAST
WEEK DISCUSSING HOW THE
PRESIDENT'S CONDUCT SUPPORTED
HIS IMPEACHMENT.
FOR THE LONGEST TIME IT'S ABOUT
QUID PRO QUO ACCORDING TO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINT BUT
AFTER WITNESS AFTER WITNESS
BEGAN SAYING THERE WAS NO QUID
PRO QUO OR EVEN THAT QUID PRO
QUO WAS NOT EVEN POSSIBLE, WE
SAW A SHIFT FROM THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY STARTED TO REFER TO THE
PRESIDENT'S CONDUCT ON THE
JULY 25TH CALL AS EXTORTION, AND
NOW IT'S SHIFTED AGAIN LAST WEEK
TO BRIBERY.
MS. WILLIAMS, YOU'VE NEVER USED
THE WORD BRIBERY OR BRIBE TO
EXPLAIN PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
CONDUCT, CORRECT?
>> NO, SIR.
>> COLONEL, YOU HAVEN'T EITHER.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> Sean: TWO OF TODAY'S MOST
SENIOR WITNESSES COMPLETELY
REFUTED THAT CLAIM, NO BRIBERY,
NO LINKAGE, WHATSOEVER BETWEEN
U.S. AID TO ANY INVESTIGATION,
NONE, ZERO, ZIP, TAKE A LOOK.
>> MR. MORRISON, I WILL START
WITH YOU, DID ANYONE EVER ASK
YOU TO BRIBE OR EXTORT ANYONE AT
ANY TIME DURING YOUR TIME IN THE
WHITE HOUSE?
>> NO, SIR.
>> YOU WERE THE TOP PERSON FOR
UKRAINE IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
CORRECT?
AT THE NSC LEVEL?
>> I WOULD ARGUE AMBASSADOR
BOLTON WOULD BE.
>> REPORTING TO AMBASSADOR
BOLTON.
>> I WAS A SENIOR OFFICIAL.
>> AMBASSADOR VOLKER YOU HAD A
STORIED CAREER AND YOU ARE THE
SPECIAL ENVOY TO UKRAINE.
>> THAT WAS CORRECT.
>> DID ANYONE AT THE WHITE HOUSE
EVER ASKED YOU TO BRIBE OR
EXTORT ANYONE AT ANY TIME?
>> NO SORA.
>> Sean: ZERO EVIDENCE, TOP
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR TO
MORRISON, EVERY WITNESS ZERO
EVIDENCE OF ANYTHING LIKE
BRIBERY, NOT EVEN MENTIONING THE
WORD ON THEIR OWN.
ZERO TIMES, DEMOCRATS WANT TO
IMPEACH A SITTING PRESIDENT OVER
THIS, THEY WON'T EVEN ALLOW,
PRECIOUS HEARSAY, AND ON
WHISTLE-BLOWER TO TESTIFY.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN SUCH MADNESS
OR INSANITY IN MY ENTIRE LIFE,
AND 31 YEARS FOLLOWING POLITICS
AND BY 24TH YEAR AT FOX, THAT'S
SAYING A LOT.
AS RANKING MEMBER DEVIN NUNES
POINTED OUT THERE'S A VERY GOOD
REASON YOU HAVE THE COMPROMISE,
CORRUPT, CONGENITAL LIAR
ADAM SCHIFF, HE WANTS TO KEEP
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER AND HIDING,
THERE'S A GOOD REASON FOR THAT
BECAUSE HE LIED AGAIN, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> WHAT WAS THE FULL EXTENT OF
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER'S PRIOR
COORDINATION WITH CHAIRMAN
SCHIFF, THE STAFF OR ANY PEOPLE
HE COOPERATED WITH PREPARING THE
COMPLAINT.
WHAT ARE THE WHISTLE-BLOWER'S
POLITICAL BIASES AND CONNECTIONS
TO DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS?
HOW DOES THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
EXPLAINED THE INACCURACIES IN
THE COMPLAINT?
WHAT CONTACTED THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHISTLE-BLOWER
HAVE WITH THE MEDIA, WHICH
APPEARS TO BE ONGOING?
WHAT ARE THE SOURCES OF THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S INFORMATION,
WHO ELSE THAT HE TALKED TO, AND
WAS THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
PROHIBITED BY LAW FROM RECEIVING
OR CONVEYING ANY OF THAT
INFORMATION?
>> Sean: DON'T FORGET, IN
SEPTEMBER, THE COMPROMISED FACT
WITNESS CONGENITAL LIAR
ADAM SCHIFF TWEETED "WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE WHISTLE-BLOWER'S
TESTIMONY.
," HE WENT ON MS DNC, WE WOULD
LIKE TO TALK TO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER, ANOTHER LIVE BY
THE CONGENITAL LIAR AND A SHORT
TIME AFTER MEDIA OUTLETS
REPORTED THAT HIS OFFICE IN FACT
REPORTED THAT HIS OFFICE IN FACW
REPORTED THAT HIS OFFICE IN FACS
REPORTED THAT HIS OFFICE IN FACA
REPORTED THAT HIS OFFICE IN FACT
REPORTED THAT HIS OFFICE IN FACL
REPORTED THAT HIS OFFICE IN FACY
MEETING AND ADVISING THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER FROM THE
BEGINNING AND SCHIFF REVERSES
OPINION.
I KNOW LONGER WANT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER TO TESTIFY AND
YET ANOTHER SHOCKING TWIST, NOW
THE CONGENITAL LIAR CLAIMS HE
KNOWS NOTHING ABOUT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S IDENTITY.
THIS IS THE LEVEL OF INSANITY
WE'VE GOT GOING ON HERE AND
CORRUPTION.
BY THE WAY, HE'S THE GUY, THAT
GUY, WHO LIED TO THIS COUNTRY
WHO FOR THREE STRAIGHT YEARS OF
SAYING "WE HAVE ALL THE EVIDENCE
OF TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION."
HE'S A LIAR, A CONGENITAL LIAR,
AND OF COURSE THE IDIOTS IN THE
MEDIA MOB THEY ARE FOLLOWING
THEIR BELOVED CONGENITAL LIAR
OVER THE CLIFF AGAIN.
TODAY ODDLY ENOUGH DESPITE
CLAIMING HE DOESN'T KNOW WHO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER IS, THE
CONGENITAL LIAR SOMEHOW KNEW
JUST WENT TO CUT OFF THE WITNESS
FROM REVEALING ANYTHING ABOUT
HIS IDENTITY, WE ARE NEVER
ALLOWED TO KNOW -- THIS
WHISTLE-BLOWER IS NOT A
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
LOOK AT THE STATUTE, WE'VE
EXAMINED IT ON THIS PROGRAM,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
HAS 17 DIFFERENT AGENCIES, WHAT
AGENCY WAS THIS INDIVIDUAL FROM?
>> IF I COULD INTERJECT HERE, WE
DON'T WANT TO USE THESE
PROCEEDINGS --
>> IT'S OUR TIME.
>> I KNOW, BUT WE NEED TO
PROTECT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
>> PLEASE STOP.
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE THERE IS
NO EFFORT TO OUT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER THROUGHOUT THESE
PROCEEDINGS.
>> I ONLY READ OUT OUTSIDE OF
THE NSC TWO INDIVIDUALS.
>> AND ARE NOT WILLING TO TELL
US WHO THE OTHER PERSON IS.
>> POINT OF ORDER, THIS
COMMITTEE WILL NOT BE USED OUT
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER, THAT SAME
NECESSITY OF PROTECTION.
>> YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AGAIN,
MR. JORDAN.
>> I DON'T SEE HOW THIS IS OUT
IN THE WHISTLE-BLOWER, THE
WITNESSES TESTIFYING HE DOESN'T
KNOW WHO THE WHISTLE-BLOWER IS,
YOU HAVE SAID EVEN THOUGH NO ONE
BELIEVES YOU, YOU HAVE SAID YOU
DON'T KNOW THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
IS, HOW IS THIS OUTING THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER TO FIND OUT WHO
THIS INDIVIDUAL IS?
>> MR. JORDAN, THIS IS YOUR TIME
FOR QUESTIONING, YOU CAN USE IT
ANYWAY YOU LIKE WHAT YOUR
QUESTIONS SHOULD NOT BE
ADDRESSED TO TRYING TO OUT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
>> Sean: CHECKMATE.
DOES THAT MEAN THE WITNESS YOU
JUST SAW LIEUTENANT COLONEL
VINDMAN LICK THE CALL TO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER?
WE KNOW HIS SUPERVISORS
EXPRESSED A LOT OF CONCERN ABOUT
HIS JUDGMENT, HE NEVER TALKED TO
THE PRESIDENT AND NEVER ADVISED
HIM DIRECTLY, HE SEEMED ANNOYED
THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T USE HIS
TALKING POINTS.
WE ALSO KNOW HE WAS UNHAPPY
ABOUT ALL OF THAT AND THAT MADE
HIM UNHAPPY WITH A PHONE CALL
ABOUT UKRAINE?
THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T FOLLOW A
SCRIPT, HE'S THE PRESIDENT, HE
IS THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF AND HE
SETS HIS OWN FOREIGN POLICY.
NOT SOME OTHER BUREAUCRAT.
I KNOW THIS MIGHT BE HARD FOR
MANY IN THE DERANGED RADICAL
EXTREME MEMBERS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY, THE
PRESIDENT IS THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
304 ELECTORAL VOTES AND YES HE
DEFEATED HILLARY CLINTON.
IF DEMOCRATS WANT TO OFFEND THE
WILL OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
THEY BETTER HAVE A LOT MORE
EVIDENCE THAN HEARSAY, DUMB,
FRANKLY WORTHLESS OPINION AND
CONJECTURE THAT DIFFERS FROM
PERSON TO PERSON.
THIS IS NOW HURTING OUR COUNTRY.
HANG ON A SECOND -- UNDERSTAND
THE SENATE IS GOING TO CONFIRM
THIS CHARADE.